heco entered valorent for one reason
i think that my goal and a hundred
thesis goal
is exactly the same my goal throughout
my entire career
has always been to win but at first
things didn't work out for him and they
actually have he go on the other side
and they get the kills immortals i
cannot believe it
so heco went back to work to rebuild
to deliver on his promise this is them
just now getting the wheels rolling so
to speak like
we haven't seen the best of 100 thieves
yet these guys are still continuing to
improve and when you think about that
over a period of time
that's terrifying and with the help of
some old friends
he proved everyone wrong carlos tries he
does
all that he can but is simply not enough
against a hundred thieves
a hundred thieves they've done it they
are your first strike
north america champions
under hiko's leadership hundred thieves
are the new kings of na valorant oh he
in just two months his super team has
taken over n a
but hiko's valerant career didn't
exactly get off to a smooth start
as you might know hiko is a north
american cs go legend
he was a major finalist and back in the
day was one of the biggest names in the
scene
so hiko and sean that's a good kill from
hika but they
dupreeh is still in there somewhere
they're going to try and go for it here
they want to go all in eco comes in
with another kill and back to a two on
two that bomb so far take they gotta
move quick right now they're going for
it the defuse is already happening hey
girl you're kidding me
he's gonna go for it they win the round
but by the end of 2019 heco was in the
twilight of his cs go career
he was no longer playing at the highest
levels of competition and he was
teamless
after he left rogue so he go turned to
streaming cs go to a couple hundred fans
growing more and more detached from the
game but then
everything changed with valorent
shot down one enemy remaining said i
think
[Music]
hiko quickly became one of the biggest
valor and streamers in the world
the new game reinvigorated his channel
as he explained on the courage and age
shot show
i mean if you compare it to one you know
literally like
two months ago right from counter-strike
you know i was
i don't want to say i was a nobody but
my streaming career and counter-strike
in general are just terrible to stream
and so it was kind of just like the new
game gave me more motivation stream
again
yeah kind of like resurrected my whole
twitch channel and
it's kind of just taking off from there
his streams were hilarious but
he was also insane at valorant
having gotten the taste of the pro play
that he left behind in cs go
hiko wanted more and in june he
got his wish so with that being said it
brings me great pleasure
to welcome the first building block of
hundred thieves our first player ever
signed to our valeran team
pico my name is spencer heco martin and
i'm the captain for 100 thieves new
valorant team
to compliment hiko 100 thieves signed
valiate
venerated ya boy dre and pride but
unlike the clutch master these guys
weren't former cs go pros
they were former pubg players and
unfortunately
they didn't do so well hiko is in a dark
cover there's five seconds left he gets
killed this sit
it's gonna be 13-10 in favor of
bbg over 100 thieves after just
two months the team disbanded with only
heco left on the roster
it would have been easy for hiko to turn
his back on pro play again and go back
to just being a streamer
after all he had a huge stream to fall
back on but
hiko still wanted to compete he knew he
wasn't some washed up
x pro he knew he could still win which
is why hundred thieves let him be the
architect of their new roster
so when i was looking at to build a new
roster of 400 thieves i
started to value a counter-strike
experience and just similar
5-5 fps games higher than i did probably
before
first up was one of the most
accomplished north american cs go
players of all time
and a former teammate nitro
nitro was one of the biggest cs go names
to switch over to valorett and he was
joining 100 thieves just a year after
winning the iem
grand slam and i didn't even open
counter strike from like july 6th
so i was kind of like just chilling and
then playing a little bit of valor here
and there but
i guess spencer kind of like noticed
that i was open to
uh offers like once he saw me playing
the game more and
he saw that um liquid bench me and stuff
like that
so we just kind of took it from there
and then yeah i mean that's kind of like
where we're at right now in the story
for nitro getting to build this new
roster alongside hiko
gave him a fresh start something he
explained in an interview with espn
um so just playing with spencer game was
a
was the main point um it wasn't just
like the work obviously a hundred these
is probably like one of the best orgs
out there it's not the best
and uh the opportunity they presented to
me was like
we could build their own roster and like
that's never happened to counter-strike
from my memory and it's something really
special and like the fact that we can
pick our teammates and like depending on
like what agents we want to play it's
just like a really special opportunity
for me
but nitro wasn't the only former cs
gopro on hiko's wish list a few weeks
later hundred thieves brought in steele
who had already moved on to valor and as
he explained on the valoranting podcast
right now it's it's valerian like cs i
like i've almost
completely mentally checked out of it
like there's nothing there
it was there i'll remember the memories
of it
the good ones mainly to balance out
these three seasoned veterans
hiko brought in asuna and dicey two
young unproven fraggers who had
previously played for immortals
we're ready for the finals it is heco vs
nitro because they are better than the
young
kids that we picked up to literally
carry us
after almost two months of rebuilding
hundred thieves new valent roster was
ready to compete
they finished top eight at their first
tournament which earned them a spot at
nsg's first strike qualifier
their first test against real top tier
competition
he thinks they're coming from that side
but they're not he's just going to
reposition eureka won't
[Music]
thieves have done it they've eliminated
tsm
and move on to the first strike major
hundred thieves shocked
everyone by beating tsm in the
quarterfinals tsm were one of the best
valorant teams in na and hundred thieves
took him out
2-0 but they didn't stop there
sentinel's looking for a prayer here
just to extend this map they're
outgunned they're outnumbered the spike
is down
everything is going against them here
video sinatra
and shazam psych just sinatra shots
again it's
nitro 100 thieves still had their
doubters though people who thought that
one good tournament result wasn't good
enough
to the haters hundred these were still
three washed up xcs pros and
two rookies but in december hundred
thieves proved they were the real deal
at first strike
the biggest tournament of the year
oh unreal stuff there from steel what a
reaction
and somehow gets the next one too these
guys are looking
so damn good right now oh that was so
beautiful but still sneaks through they
don't see steel coming through the back
side
he finds a second kill the headshot from
steel
are so damaging there's still three
versus two here for t1 looking good
dicey and hiko though get all of them
down braxton kim
it's that lone i believe he just spotted
both of them
what a huge fight by austin and hiko
closes out the match
through the phoenix wall once again
hundred thieves made it all the way to
the finals
beating t1 and sentinels to get there
despite pretty much
everyone betting against them and i want
to come to you once again on this
hundred these roster because i think
it's a forgotten
thing that this was the two seat coming
into the tournament i feel like every
step of the way to a degree this hundred
thieves roster has been
under-appreciated and they have shown up
in such a big way to refute
any of that dissent that may have
existed within the community or even
from us here on the desk
100th's final opponent was a revitalized
tsm
after losing to 100 thieves in the
qualifier tsm rebounded
they tore through the first strike
bracket even beating envy the team that
won the qualifier by beating hundred
thieves tsm
had it all solid results some of the
best players in the game
and with their biggest competition out
of the bracket they were strong
favorites to win the tournament
but if hundred thieves were able to beat
tsm
right then and there there was no
doubting them anymore
you versus four for tsm they have to
find a way out of the situation but it's
getting
worse and worse and who better than hiko
to look to seal the deal here
in this grand finals as carlos tries he
does
all that he can but it's simply not
enough against a hundred thieves
a hundred thieves they've done it they
are your first strike
north america champions hundred thieves
demolished tsm
three to one completely outclassing
their competition
and heco proved once again why they call
him the clutch master
heco leading the charge as the team
captain for them and ultimately
clutching up how many times 17 trillion
times
hiko's road back to the top wasn't easy
he had to go through a bad roster
rebuild for months and then prove
himself time and time again
but in the end he created a valorant
juggernaut
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages